It's great to welcome back to the program
today. Shane Dixon Cavenaugh, who's staff
porter with the Oregonian in Portland. You
might remember that he recently joined us
to talk about a story that, uh, he's been
following for some time now involving a Saudi
nationals, uh, who in the United States are,
um, accused of crimes, sometimes arrested
and they disappear and he'll tell us what
we mean by disappear specifically, uh, before
they actually face justice. So Shane, first
of all, great to have you back on. Catch us
up on what we discussed last time to get everybody
up to speed, if you will. Yes,
David, thanks so much for having me back on
your show. So as you mentioned, for the last
few months, I've been working on an investigative
series here at the Oregonian looking into
cases where Saudi nationals, most of them
attending university here in the United States,
um, have been charged with serious crimes
ranging from manslaughter to rape, to possession
of child pornography. And these individuals,
a large number, a growing number of them,
uh, have managed to disappear a while facing
prosecution. Essentially these individuals
had been charged with crimes. They end up
posting bail, uh, have been, uh, retained
private attorneys. And then as they're moving
close to trial, uh, a number of these individuals
suddenly go missing. And, uh, a number of
them we've been able to track back to Saudi
Arabia.
So some of the questions I asked you last
time and the answers were some form of we're
looking into that include what do we know
about what American authorities know about
this? What do we know about the sort of, um,
uh, of financial or, or sort of sociopolitical
status of these individuals in Saudi Arabia.
And so it sort of to try to understand the
contours of what may be going on. What have
you learned as your investigation has continued
since we last talked about this?
Yeah. A good place to sort of start with that
question is to just sort of stay out front
that what got us looking into these cases
originally was a single case here in Portland
where we learn that federal law enforcement
who looked into a Saudi national here in Portland,
who disappeared before his manslaughter trial
in 2017, uh, federal law enforcement concluded
that they believe the Saudi Arabian government
had played a role in orchestrating this individual's
escape, uh, from prosecution. Uh, this individual
was picked up in a black SUV outside of his
home. He cut his ankle monitor and then a
federal law enforcement belief he was given
in elicit passport and possibly smuggled out
of the United States on a private plane. So
that's what got us looking into whether or
not there are other cases like this one here
in Oregon and around the country. And in the
last few months, we have now documented nearly
30 cases where, uh, similar, uh, similar circumstances
have unfolded.
And so one of the questions we've been raising
from the beginning is whether or not the Saudi
Arabian government might be involved in more
of these uh, escapes. And also the question
of has the u s government known about this?
And uh, in answer to your question, our most
recent story that came out two weeks ago in
partnership with Propublica, the nonprofit
investigative news website, uh, who helped
us on this most recent story, we found that
the Department of Homeland Security and the
FBI have, uh, since around 2008 known about
the Saudi Arabian students disappearing from
the United and had identified a Saudi operatives
here in the US that had helped a number of
these students, uh, escape from the US.
Is there anything that you've uncovered so
far? So, okay. To be clear, authorities, American
authorities became aware of some of these
cases, presumably, I want to make sure I'm
understanding correctly. We believe after
the fact, not as these individuals were facing
prosecution,
correct. Uh, what we, what we're able to find
is that back in 2008 analysts with the Department
of Homeland Security began looking into a
number of cases that had come up or come to
their attention where a Saudi nationals, mostly
college students who are charged with crimes
and then were disappearing from the United
States. So they began looking into this phenomenon
and quickly determined that they believe that,
uh, members of the Saudi Arabian government
working through the Saudi cultural mission
in Washington DC, uh, we're assisting these,
a suspected suspected criminals, uh, facilitating
their escape from the United States. And there
was actually a report on this produced by
the Department of Homeland Security back in
2008, which they then gave to the FBI. Uh,
but it appears that, uh, that report was never
distributed more widely throughout the intelligence
community here in the US. And, uh, what we
also learned through our reporting is that
a, you know, this issue has come up time and
time again on the radars of federal law enforcement
officials in the FBI, homeland security. The
State Department has been aware of this yet
nobody in the US government has you really,
um, taken up the issue serious
now there's no reason to believe at this point
in time that there's any American complicity
in this right. Or at least at this point in
time you've not found evidence of that. Is
that correct?
Well, what do you mean by complicity?
Well, I dunno. What do you, what, what should,
I mean, in other words, is there anything
you've uncovered so far that suggests that
given that there is no extradition treaty
with Saudi Arabia, given that many of these
individuals have or able to get access to
resources to get out that don't involve commercial
flights and they involve a, you know, potentially
false passports, do you have any reason to
think that American authorities are aware
of the potential flight risk of some of these
individuals as the cases are unfolding and
either look the other way or even potentially
assist in getting them out of the country?
That's actually a really great question, David.
And I think at this time, uh, we don't have
a real clear understanding on that matter.
What we can say is that, uh, you know, this
has been an issue that's been on the radar
of the federal law enforcement for a debt,
you know, up to a decade. They knew that this
was happening. And, uh, you know, it appears
that during that time period where a number
of these individuals were escaping justice
in the United States, uh, the u s government
never made an issue about it or even confronted
the Saudi Arabian government, an ally of the
u s about this issue.
Do you have, uh, what, what are the logistics
at, at the sort of individual case level?
In other words, do you have reason to believe
that the Saudi individuals know in advance
that if you get into trouble, here's who you
have to call? Is it that, where is the bail
money coming from? Are they getting themselves
bailed out and later contacting Saudi, uh,
assistance? Or is this something that, uh,
Saudi, uh, Saudi consulate for example, might
be handling from the beginning of what, what
do you know about those details?
Right. So, uh, I think to answer that question,
the first thing we, that we have to sort of
point out or illustrate is that, uh, there
has been a tremendous influx in the number
of Saudi students studying in the United States,
uh, in the last decade plus starting in about
2005, most of these students in the u s are
recipients of a government scholarship program
by the Saudi Arabian government. And, uh,
one of the things that we learned and kind
of had already known about before this latest
story came out, but that the Saudi government
keeps very close tabs on all of their students
who are studying here in the United States.
I mean, it appears that through the Saudi
cultural mission, they sort of have a, uh,
large surveillance program to keep an eye
on students just to make sure that a, they're
staying out of trouble or that they're not
engaging in political activity or that they're,
uh, you know, not talking to the wrong people,
et Cetera, et cetera.
So the, our understanding is that the Saudi
government has pretty close tabs on most of
their students. And so are able to find out
pretty quickly when some of them have gotten
into serious legal trouble. Uh, in almost
all of the cases that we've documented to
date, uh, after an individual against jailed
on, uh, you know, uh, on suspicion of whatever
crime, uh, the Saudi Arabian government as
a policy. And they've told us this explicitly
as a policy, we'll post the bail money for
any individual, any citizen of their, is accused
of a crime in the United States, and then
also provide money for legal representation
so they don't have a, you know, a, a public
defender or something like that. So in some
of these cases, the Saudis have put up substantial
sums of money for these individuals accused
of crimes. Um, you know, we're talking a six
figure sums of bail money, uh, that's put
up by various consulates Saudi consulates
here in the US. You know, many of the ones
we've looked at here in Oregon, cause we've
documented a number of cases here, uh, that's
come from the closest consulate to, to us
in Oregon is the Saudi Arabian consulate in
Los Angeles.
So you mentioned some of some items that were
told to you about how this works, um, from,
from Saudi authorities, but have they answered
any direct questions about the fact that some
of these individuals are disappearing and
evading justice or have they not, uh, answered
the questions related to that?
It's been a little difficult getting detailed
explanations from the Saudi embassy in Washington,
which has been sort of our main point of contact
throughout this a series. But they have sort
of given a blanket denial, uh, that the, that
their government has helped anybody or any
Saudi citizen Drake US laws and escape prosecution
in the United States.
Are there any explanations for any, any parts
of this? I mean, in total it seems very hard
that this would apply, but are there any parts
of this that if we said, let's be less a cynical,
skeptical, whatever term you want to apply,
that there were some, some kind of innocent
explanation for some parts of this?
Well, I think maybe the most, if we could
even call it an innocent explanation, um,
you know, I think it's a, it's a matter of,
uh, maybe there is that the Saudi Arabian
government has very little faith in the US
criminal justice system or there might be
a sort of ingrained belief, especially after
nine 11, that, uh, you know, Arab men in the
US who were accused of certain crimes are
not going to get a, you know, a fair shake
in the US criminal justice system and, uh,
you know, instead of taking a chance of going
to trial and facing years in prison, uh, they're
making the decision to help these, uh, individuals,
uh, escape and return to Saudi Arabia. Um,
I mean that could be the most innocent explanation,
but it would still require a foreign government,
an ally of the United States subverting, uh,
are you, are the US justice system and also
violating a number of us and international
laws.
Has the Trump administration been presented
with this? I know you've been in touch with
some senators and if so, what have they said
about it?
Well at this point in time, it's, it's abundant.
It is, uh, you know, explicitly clear that
the Trump administration does know about our
reporting and our findings. Senators in Washington
have raised this question multiple times with
various agencies in the Trump administration.
Uh, they've responded finally, um, after ignoring
a number of our questions and queries throughout
this process because we've written more than
a dozen stories on this now. So they're aware
of this, they're aware of our findings, and
they're aware that we now know that the u
s government prior to the Trump administration
has known about this, you know, both in the
George W. Bush administration and, uh, under
President Barack Obama. However, now that
this has been revealed, uh, it's sort of,
uh, in the Trump administration's court to
do something about it or choose not to do
anything. And at this point in time, it doesn't
appear, uh, based on everything we know that
a, they're particularly interested in raising
this issue.
Yeah. I mean, this now starts to get more
into Saudi U s relations. But there is this
question which I mentioned have an extradition
treaty with Saudi Arabia, which is not currently
in place. Would, I mean imagining that that
was put in place, would that mostly a preempt
the utility of getting these individuals out
to Saudi Arabia or, or would that only deal
with part of the issue?
Well, I think that, uh, you know, the idea
of the Saudi Arabian government agreeing to
an extradition treaty with the United States
is just, um, I mean not even a, an idea of
where it's entertaining, it's never going
to happen. Um, but clearly, uh, without an
extradition treaty, once these individuals
are able to get out of the United States and
return home, there is really no mechanism
in place to have these fugitives brought back
to the u s unless they end up going to a country
where the US has an extradition treaty, say
one of these individuals goes back home to
Saudi Arabia, and then several years later
decides to go on a vacation in Europe somewhere
they can get picked up and extradited back
to the u s that way. Um, but otherwise, uh,
if they get back to Saudi Arabia for the time
being, um, there seems to be little a, the
u s can do if they don't want to apply political
or diplomatic pressure on the Saudis and,
uh, you know, up until now they've chosen
not to do that.
Yeah. And no indication as you're suggesting
that that piece is going to change any, anytime
soon. Really. Excellent.
Yeah. With that, with that point there. I
mean, uh, the State Department in a letter
to Senator Ron Wyden who is a senator from
Oregon who was asking the State Department
about, uh, you know, the, uh, all of these
Saudis disappearing and returning home the
State Department roadway in a letter a couple
of months ago and essentially said that there
was nothing that they could do about this.
They basically said it was a law enforcement
issue, not a diplomatic issue, which is false
because the State Department, there's a number
of things the State Department could do on
this particular issue. But you know, the sort
of implication from the letter was that they
weren't going to do anything.
We've been speaking with Fan Dixon Cavenaugh
staff reporter with the Oregonian in Portland,
Oregon. Uh, Shane, really appreciate you getting
us up to speed and continue
the good work on this. I really appreciate
your interest in this issue